[Music]
i'm barrel
and this week
we're looking at breakfasts
let's go
breakfast wasn't always such a beloved
meal in fact in the middle ages in
europe it was considered an affront to
god to eat so early on in the day
but then in the 1600s coffee and tea
arrived in europe and things began to
change
coffee smells so good i did an
around-the-world coffee actually if
you're interested link
okay
then came the industrial revolution and
people needed an actual full meal in the
morning to get them through a big day of
labor
i broke the
yolk whatever
kellogg and post then came onto the
scene
toasters were invented waffle irons were
invented breakfast became a huge thing
quickly
[Music]
oh
hi buddy
oh my god he can't have my breakfast
[Music]
well
to be fair that history lesson was
really just about the us and europe but
around the world breakfast is important
and the foods vary wildly country to
country and personally breakfast is my
favorite meal of the day so i really
wanted to make this episode
i got to speak to seven people in seven
countries to see what breakfast was like
around the world
so this
is the breakfast episode
[Music]
in making this episode i decided two
things one i love eggs but i'm not
looking at egg-led breakfasts so no
omelets or frittatas or quiches that was
my choice and two
i'm looking at breakfast to redefine my
narrow western scope of what breakfast
is
before we begin i want to say this i
know that seven is a paltry number it
really doesn't do justice to the amazing
diversity of breakfast foods around the
world so i'm hoping that maybe the
comment section can look a bit like a
breakfast menu let me know what
breakfast is like where you live and if
you know an amazing recipe leave it
because i love cooking and i will
totally try
okay
i hope you guys enjoy the video let's do
it
breakfast is a savory meal where i live
in baruch
and we can make it more spicy if you
like it and less spice if you don't like
it
we could eat grits in the salad just
about every day it is a very popular
breakfast food
we're going to begin in vietnam because
this breakfast soup really challenged me
to rethink about what a breakfast food
is we're beginning with eel soup
[Music]
night
[Music]
you
[Music]
in kenya breakfast can be a simple
affair but their versions of fried dough
look way better than anything i've tried
here in new york
[Music]
it was tiffany
nice
[Music]
[Music]
i believe that cheese is always a great
idea for breakfast
and then i found this dish from turkey
and i just
we had to film it
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
breakfast in the u.s has serious range
but it is way more than waffles and
pancakes and in the south they do it
right
breakfast is a very important meal of
the day however when it comes to having
grits it's typically something that you
might see happening more often on the
weekend my name is darius williams and i
live in atlanta georgia
a typical breakfast in the south
includes fish and grits although you can
get grits pretty much all over the
country they're very very popular in
lots of southern states simply because
grits come from the native americans and
we sort of have adopted them in the
south
i learned how to make grits from
watching my grandmother i would just
literally sit in awe and watch her as
she caressed that pot of grits into the
creamy delicacy that it is
for catfish and grits we're gonna take
catfish fillets that are gonna get
soaked in buttermilk and then deep fried
until they're golden brown and delicious
we're gonna put that on top of some
amazing creamy wonderful
grits uh we're gonna do a little bit of
tomato right on top because what else is
southern besides tomato catfish and
grits with a little bit of cream it is
to die for
the most difficult part about making
grits is getting it to be the right
consistency you can't rush it this is a
thing of love
[Music]
when i think about
what happens over a pot of grits it is
hearing the laughters and the
conversation between all of our families
sort of connecting and spending time
with each other i firmly believe that
food and cooking is the way to connect
with
your family
india has a lot of amazing dishes but
these steamed ones from the south of the
country caught my eye
i'm making dhokla and patra today this
breakfast is typical in my country my
name is aniri chavan i live in baruch
india
dhukla is fermented rice and urad dal
patra is colocasia leaves which are
coated with gram flour and it is steamed
and also fried
dhokla is mildest and patra is a spicier
thing
it takes eight to nine hours to make
dhokla the most difficult part is the
fermenting part
when you have to mix it in the mixer the
batter should have the desired
consistency to achieve that it is bit
difficult
patra's difficult part is coating them
with the gram flour and just binding
them and folding them any chance the
pole gets open then it is of no fun
breakfast in my house is a sitting down
affair my son my husband he three have
the pictures in the morning together
only before leaving for the job
this dishes are quite steamed and
healthy so i like them the most it gives
you lot of mileage to work for the
entire day
[Music]
some have called this next breakfast
from lebanon pizza like and i'm not sure
that's the best description however damn
if it is not amazing
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the final breakfast dish is another soup
this one is from myanmar and it has so
many flavors that it feels like the
perfect dish to set yourself up for the
day
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i know that people always say breakfast
is the most important meal of the day
and it is
but i don't think that we really execute
on that i think a lot of times we're in
a rush and we're kind of running out the
door and breakfast is kind of an
afterthought
but i also know that on those days when
i do sit down and i do eat a good meal
and i eat it with somebody that i care
about my family or my friends i feel
like my day is better you know you have
this moment where you're sharing a meal
it's the first meal of your day and kind
of the day is full of possibilities and
sharing that with somebody before
everything gets going
kind of sets you up for a better day
you know
cooking always makes the family unite
together my husband my child they always
help me while cooking so it is
absolutely a family affair for us
[Music]
foreign
grits because they just taste good and
it is also a tradition so every time
you're eating a bowl of grits you are
reliving this tradition this sort of
practice that you had as a family and it
brings you back to those moments that
sometimes we just don't have enough
opportunity to connect with
you